but we begin this morning with a massive
manhunt that is underway after a
stabbing spree left at least 10 people
dead and another 15 wounded police are
searching right now for these two
suspects who share a last name this
happened yesterday in a rural area in
the province of saskatchewan
matt piper is following the latest
developments
it is horrific what has occurred in our
province today royal canadian mounted
police say damian sanderson and miles
sanderson are on the run after a series
of stabbings across at least 13
different crime scenes
the priority right now is to locate them
and and
make sure that we have them
in custody so that we can ensure the
public of their safety the relationship
between the suspects is unclear
authorities say they received a call
about a stabbing on the james smith cree
nation at 5 40 a.m within minutes
officials received more calls about
multiple stabbings across the region
officers were dispatched to the
community immediately as the first
dangerous persons alert was sent out for
the area at 7 12 a.m
several additional alerts were sent
before the suspect's car was spotted
about 200 miles away in saskatchewan's
capital regina around noon police so far
do not have a motive it appears that
some of the victims may have been
targeted and some may be random while
mass killings are rare in canada this is
among the country's deadliest in recent
years
in 2020 22 were killed after a man shot
people in their homes and set fires in
nova scotia while in 2018 10 were killed
in toronto when a man drove into
pedestrians for cbs mornings i'm matt
piper